historic week coming up this week
impeachment I don't know if your chip
there cheering the actual impeachment or
just who know people love impeach made
it yeah they don't care who gets
impeached somebody yeah the network's
gonna be like we gotta get this going
every night this is great this is big
this week nine witnesses are gonna be
testifying in the impeachment inquiry
nine yeah in other words the president
his team were hard at work all weekend
coming up with nine stupid nicknames
soggy song then they're just thinking if
Fiona you know they're doing that's what
they're doing
the good news we just have our positive
news could very good news for Pete
Buddha judge Pete Buddha judge is now
leading the polls in Iowa yeah after
hearing this bitter or work said damn it
I knew I should have been gay that was
so the way to go presidential candidate
Pete Buddha judge unveiled his plan to
make college more affordable
yeah his plan don't go hey
essentially what is that why is there a
groundswell of love for not getting an
education Conan it's our audience oh
you're right for God